let's go next to our caller from the
five four zero area code who's there at
five four zero today five four zero
that's you can you hear me can you hear
me yes we can hear you who's this hey
I'm calling the regards to the interview
you did the other day about all the rest
of us scandal which interview is that oh
I don't remember the guys name but it
was just the other day maybe just a week
ago okay I interviewed a guy you're
saying um I think he may have had
connections with the CIA oh oh I I was
interviewed on the Tom woods show
opposite former CIA analyst Ray McGovern
yeah okay yes so um basically I wanted
to kind of confirm with you to see if
maybe because he brought up a lot of
good points and I'm with you with the
whole rest of scandal there's definitely
a lot of sketchy stuff going on but you
didn't seem like a normal character who
favors Donald Trump and that's what he's
pretending like none of this exists I
had felt that he brought up some good
points yeah about basically how maybe
the Democrats do look I guess my
question is is it possible that this
investigation the Mueller investigation
has come from something that wasn't
necessarily I guess the right thing but
it could turn out that it brings up well
you're bringing up a couple different
issues here so first of all I think that
the circumstantial evidence around
Russia is what led to the investigation
right I don't think it was you know
hidden political grievances or anything
like that your question is an
interesting one which is that Ray
McGovern didn't seem like just your
trumpet denier of the Russia scandal
that's not unique I've talked before
about this contingent of the left that
sees the Russia scandal as a proxy
endorsement or support of Hillary
Clinton and I've made it abundantly
clear
that's not what it means it's an
investigation based on a whole ton of
really sketchy financial and
circumstantial evidence including quid
pro quo discussions in Trump Tower with
a Russian lawyer etc etc etc so I think
you're you were correctly identifying
Ray McGovern as not just at rumpus
ideologue who's denying the Russia story
for that reason he is in the camp of
those I mean look his first eye I laid
out a whole bunch of assertions and
instead of refuting them he immediately
went into Hillary Clinton also did
opposition research and that I think we
really exposed his motivations and
they're not really rare there's a
contingent of the left that's in his
camp okay well I appreciate the answer
David all right thank you thank you for
calling in yeah good to clear that up
because I think there was people
immediately realize that Ray McGovern
was not a trumpet yet he seemed to sort
of be a little bit disconnected from the
facts on a lot of these things